[Musique]
la décision de harry et mégane de
quitter la famille royale et de s'ôter
la vie royale pour nos moins six mois de
l'année je pense marque un tournant dans
l'avenir de la famille royale
britannique
un trop long pour reconstruire un avenir
alors que du côté de la reine la
pérennisation de la famille royale est
assuré mais ses fondements sont en train
d'être bouleversée par cette décision de
rallier mégane de portières et la cour
de la reine de leur donner raison
et de dire oui vous pouvez porter à
condition qu'on trouve un compromis
entre nous ça veut dire que désormais
pour d'autres membres de la famille
royale la porte de sortie est ouverte
donc ce que l'on vit avec harry mégane
est très important c'est un tournant
dans une famille royale qui cherche
toujours à se moderniser à être dans
l'air du temps et donc la décision de la
reine manque pour moi un événement
marque honte quand igor dodon l'avenir
comme un début de changement pour les
mondes du famille royale qui ne
souhaitait plus jouer ce rôle à plein
temps il ya une grande malaise dans le
couple et mégane qui divisible année
dernier à l'o2 entretien à la télévision
britannique
un premier entretien à paris exprime sa
tristesse vis-à-vis de sa situation le
fait qu'avec son frère william les
relations ont quelques pas changé et le
fait qu'ils ne souhaitent lui on tourne
le clip des journalises les appareils
photos qui le ramène immédiatement à son
passé et son enfance quand il voyait sa
mère pourchassés par la presse tabloïde
du côté de megan elle aussi raconte que
l est pourchassé partout pas une presse
sans scrupules et peu de personnes
s'intéressent à elle même dans ce
qu'elle pense comment elle va comment
elle a vécu à la nation et l'office
[Musique]
harry mégane sont très fortunés harry a
reçu 7 millions de livres à la mort de
sa mère en 1997 mégane a une fortune
estimée aux alentours de 5 millions de
dolla après sa carrière de comédienne
dont sud
d'autant plus que s'il quitte la grande
bretagne il installe une bonne partie de
l'année au canada
ils sont le sujet de beaucoup de
propositions de travail à savoir décret
délivre également de créer leur propre
ligne de vêtements ou de nourriture qui
rapportera beaucoup d'argent donc ils ne
sont pas à court d'idées pour gagner de
l'argent
la chose est de savoir comment ça va
être organisé pour ne pas causer
problème avec leur vie du membre de la
famille royale
tout cela c'est en cours de discussion
actuellement avec la haine et je pense
qu'un compromis s'est retrouvé dans un
délai assez bref
[Musique]